and the growth and the maturation of
victor reyes just continues on a
day-to-day basis he's become
a very important staple in this lineup
drives one to deep right hooking and
that ball's gone victor reyes starts to
saturday now
with a bang his fourth homer of the
season one-nothing tigers one thing that
victor does well in that ball down is he
really stays through it
gets extension does not hook
he struck that out front looks like
something about speed
just real slow look at his leg kick how
slow it is
that's why you get the quick hands
tigers up one nothing
two and two
what's he gonna do
she's been going in and out she's gonna
double up in good pitch
strikeout number four for terex scooble
take a look at the motion and let's look
at how the arm goes behind the head and
it quickly comes through
[Music]
very confident they understand what two
strikes mean the 2-2 on the ground could
be the double play ball that you needed
and it is as candelario took the high
throw and came down on the bag
good way to get out of it
for tarik skubal and the tigers as we
head to the fifth
tough for the twins to get something
going i don't know about you but what
point of a game do you start talking
about a no-hitter is it the fifth yeah
five innings yeah if he does
two strikes to rooker
hit a ground ball to the third baseman
paredes his first time up
to right field bonifacio coming over and
won't get there it's a base hit right
off the end of the bat the lead off man
is on
and i know you don't believe in the
power of the booth nope talking about
metal hitters and all the rest of that
but
look at that
that's brent rooker's hit you had
nothing to do with that 100
driven to right a rifle shot
and cave around second on his way to
third
and the pinch running move pays off with
an extra base here in the fifth inning
trying to throw that fastball by him he
beat him with it earlier and
earlier in the game in his first step
out and now he goes up there and
it's an absolute rocket
back to the pitcher and they'll go for a
double play cave will score and the
twins have tied it up
and scuba was spun and fired to second
base had he wanted to get cave he would
have had a chance to get him because he
was already halfway to home plate this
is a decision to make as a pitcher right
here your thought is
we saw him
a little frustration his instincts told
him just to spin and throw
i got him slider down
he has been in control
since the reyes home run went down his
ability to execute it's just amazing
[Music]
he's made one mistake in this game to
lead off
homer but everyone after that has been
fringes of the strike zone
to below and just off of the strike zone
it's it's
it's an impressive display of pitching
he wants you to be convinced that he's
gonna try and sneak a fastball by you
like he attempted right there and
keep that in your mind that you're not
gonna be able to catch up to it and then
get you out front on something off speed
like the splitter
strikeout number eight for my aida and
another three up three down inning
and the twins coming to bat
kenta maeda has retired 18 men in a row
[Music]
constant discussion of baseball and
constantly learning another payoff and
scope draws a lead-off walk
first free pass for detroit here tonight
and he finds a whole left side base hit
from miguel cabrera scope's going to try
to take turn and he does head first
slide and heads up base running on the
part of jonathan scope to put runners at
the corners with nobody down
i'm not sure because we couldn't see
here he may have been running
whatever the case may be he had a heck
with
he was on the move
big play by ron garden higher put him in
move trusty miguel put the pressure on
him
and just barely gets in there and stays
right on that bag
rocco buldelli's going to his bullpen
tyler clifford comes on to face jamer
candelario with runners at the corners
candelario whips one to right
that brings home jonathan scope on the
very first pitch he sees
he delivers the go-ahead run and jamer
candelario and the tigers come through
here in the seventh to lead at 2-1
here's the 1-2
back up the middle base hit
bonifacio loves it when the bases are
loaded cabrera comes home
and the bases remain loaded it's 3-1
tigers as bonifacio delivers again big
inning for detroit here in the seventh
just puts the barrel on it it's a hangar
thinking middle
infield's in
that's a walk
what's that four hits in a row four
straight singles station to station for
the tigers they lead by two one strike
deep to left field steward back and that
ball's gone
in a hurry
off the facing of the second deck and
it's three to two
snow fired up after that he
he hung him with slider
he stood there and admired it but
[Applause]
took a little time getting out of the
batter's box he had something to say
might be igniting a rivalry right there
between these two teams but
that was an absolute missile
just the fifth home run allowed by
jimenez decent speed at second adrianz
is the tying run
ground ball base hit left field audrey
onto around third he's coming in the
throw to the plate is not in time and
ceno delivers a single to tie the game
you get maida off the hook we threw the
ball so well not deserving of a loss in
this game but
look at snow simplifies the swing just
concentrates on putting this ball in
play
you got the pitch runner age rounds in
there
nice turn able to score and that'll fire
the tigers up that'll fire the twins up
really important for him to try and put
this ball in play
two and two to buckston
[Applause]
slowly left side buxton flying down the
line he beat it and the twins win the
game
a four hopper to the shortstop
and buxton's blazing speed walks off the
tigers yeah bucks and celebrating like
you know as a runner when you're safe
and he feels like he beat that but the
importance of being able to put the ball
in play with two strikes make an
adjustment a routine play for everybody
else in the league except probably that
guy